bienvenue vous avez été sélectionné pour
passer 50 jours dans la chambre
immaculée et vous gagnerez 5 millions de
dollars pour l'accomplissement de la
mission profitez bien de votre séjour
dans la chambre immaculée
[Musique]
on se croirait dans un rêve pas vrai
c'est une deuxième chance pour nous non
on devrait être connaissant
c'est tout un bon parfum de néant alors
ça j'imagine que c'est la chambre
principale vraiment
très blanc
ceci est votre alarme de réveil
[Musique]
pourquoi tu crois qu'il fait tout ça le
professeur voyant tout ce qu'on sait à
propos de lui c'est que l'argent lui
sort par les oreilles qu'il est intrigué
par la condition humaine c'est
maintenant l'après-midi je te tais ce
horloge elle a l'air
[Applaudissements]
il veut nous jouer dans la tête c'est ça
je vais prendre une gâterie
salut qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette
pièce tout à coup elle était là
j'étais au courant de rien ça va être
très amusant
bonne nuit
je crois pas que je peux continuer comme
ça tout ça c'est un peu ridicule
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est pas tout le
monde qui se laisse manipuler
[Musique]
profitez bien de votre séjour